SPEAKER: Welcome to an extended
episode of the "What's What--
Service Accounts" series.
In this video, I'm going to
demonstrate a few of the things
that we talked about in some
of the previous episodes.
If you haven't caught
those yet, check them
out in the description.
Without further ado, let's see
service accounts in action.
For this first
demonstration, I'm
going to show you how to create
a compute instance with a user
managed service
account attached to it
and how a user with
access to this instance
is able to use that
service account.
In this example, in addition
to the project viewer role,
my user account is granted
the compute admin role
on the project, so I can create
and manage compute instances.
I also have the role
service account user ,
but only for a service
account called bucket admin,
and not the entire project.
The bucket admin service
account has a role storage admin
assigned to it that allows it to
create and manage GCS buckets.
OK, let's start by creating a
compute instance by going over
here in Compute Engine.
Create.
If you scroll down
here, this is where
you'll indicate
what service account
you want to use for
your compute instance.
So let's pick one that I
don't have any access to.
Let's pick sequel
admin and hit create.
And you'll see that
this isn't going
to work because I have no roles
assigned to my user account
over this service account.
And there it goes.
You hover over this
little red circle.
It says it right there that I
need the service account user
role on that service account.
So let's just delete this
and create a new instance
with the right service account.
So once again, we're
going to scroll down here
and this time I'm going to
pick the bucket admin service
account, which I
do have access to.
I am the service account user
for that service account.
So give that a second
while it creates.
Boom, there it is.
Green check mark means that
the instance is running.
So next I'm going to show
you that I don't have access
to create a bucket.
Using GS Util down here, I'm
going to try to make a bucket
and this should fill.
And yes, access denied.
So I don't have access
to create a bucket,
but I do have access to
SSH into this instance.
And now that I'm in there, I
can show you with gcloud offlist
that the credential
account isn't me.
It's the service account
attached to the VM
and there it is bucket admin.
So if I'm admin,
that means I should
be able to create a bucket,
even though I couldn't
do that as myself before.
So let's try that.
Gsutil.
Make bucket.
A new bucket.
And there it is.
No error message, and that's
because I created a bucket
as a service account.
Note that I only needed
the service account user
role to attach the service
account to the instance.
But to use a service account
from the compute instance,
I just needed to
have SSH access.
That's really important
to keep in mind for users
to have access to your VMs.
For this next demonstration,
I'm going to generate a key
and show you how I can use it
to act as a service account
to access resources.
This time, I'm going to
be a user with a viewer
role in the project,
and the service
account key Admin role granted
only on a service account
called SQL admin.
That service account has a
Cloud SQL Admin role sign,
so it's able to create
new Cloud SQL instances
and manage any that are
already in the project.
If you wanted to create
a service account
key through the Cloud console,
here's how you do that.
Under IM in Admin, service
accounts and hit that menu
right next to the account that
you want to create a key for.
There should be a create
key option right there.
But for this
demonstration, I'm going
to use the Cloud Shell, someone
to create a key down here.
$ gcloud, iam, service
accounts, keys create,
followed by a file name, and
then we're going to indicate
the iam account that we
want to create a key for.
So remember this will only work
if you have the service account
key admin role
assigned and since I
don't have that
role assigned to me,
project wide, if I put a service
account I don't have access
to budget admin, it won't work.
See?
Permission denied.
So let's put in
a service account
that I do have that
role signed for
and that would be a SQL admin.
And that worked so now
the private key was
saved to that key.json file
I indicated in the command.
You can check the keys that
already exists with Gcloud IAM
service-accounts keys list,
followed by the IAM account
flag and the service
account that you
want to see a list of keys for.
The output for this is going to
include the key I just created
as well as a system manage key
that was added when the service
account was created.
So now that we have a key, let's
see what I can do with that.
So first, let me just
show you that I do not
have any roles or permissions
that allow me to create a Cloud
SQL instance.
So let's try to
create one as myself.
And this should fail.
Yes.
So I don't have that permission.
But my service account does.
So how do I use it?
Gcloud auth activate
service account followed
by the service account name.
And then indicate the key file.
That was key.json.
Boom.
Activated service
account credentials.
So to verify that,
Gcloud auth list
will show that SQL admin is
the active account right now.
And that means now if I try to
create another SQL instance,
it should work.
And success.
So remember, the service
account key admin role was only
used to create the key.
A user with as little
as a project viewer role
will still be able
to use that key
to act as a service account.
So be sure to have a really
secure way of distributing
that key and a decent key
rotation process in place.
This last demonstration is
going to be like the last one,
except I'm going to be
impersonating a service
account without keys.
My user account will only have
the viewer role in the project.
On the IAM policy of the
service account SQL admin,
I'm going to have the service
account token creator role
and nothing else.
Let's see what I
can do with that.
So for this
demonstration, I'm just
going to delete the
database instance that I
created in the last example.
So I'll try to do
that first as myself.
So Gcloud SQL instances delete
followed by the instance name.
Hit Yes.
And there you go.
I am not authorized
to make that request.
But now let me run
the same command.
Except this time, I'm going
to add the impersonate service
account flag followed by
the service account name.
Do I want to continue?
I'm going to say yes.
And as you can see, something
is happening this time.
And the Cloud SQL
instance is deleted.
And I was able to do that
without having any roles having
to do with Cloud SQL assigned
to me and without the use
of any service account keys.
All I had was a service account
token creator role on that one
service accounts IAM policy.
The impersonate
service account flag
works on any Gcloud command
and is the most straightforward
example of how you can use the
service account token creator
role.
The role also lets users
create short lived credentials
and generate service
account access tokens
so they can send requests
to the Google Cloud REST API
as a service account.
Well, that's that
for "What's What."
What do you think of the series?
Do you have any other questions
about service accounts?
Feel free to let us know
in the comments below.
And to learn more
about service accounts,
visit cloud.google.com
/iam/docs/service-accounts.
Thanks for watching.
And see you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]